6 43 Welcome Back mental health top of
mind for Las Vegas fire and rescue as
firefighters deal with a high number of
suicides our Laura negretti joining us
live near Bonanza and Las Vegas
Boulevard with this new Initiative for
local Crews pretty unique Lauren good
morning
good morning yes we got some Crews
coming in trickling this morning right
now here at the Cashman Center for some
other training here but meantime their
Las Vegas fire and rescues Behavioral
Health administrator says the national
suicide rate for firefighters has
increased locally it's fluctuated and
now they're gearing up with some unique
training here to cope with mechanisms
there including yoga for recruits
push your back
raise it your head before their final
test to join the team Las Vegas fire and
rescue recruits practice Wellness it
allows us to kind of decompress and get
that stress off of our shoulders and go
into these tests with a level mind and a
level body it's an effort to address
first responder mental health and
suicide rates firefighter Morgan yuhas
says theirs is a labor of love but it
comes with a lot of stress let them know
that we have resources like exercise or
therapists and stuff like that hopefully
we can see that Trend go down the yoga
class is part of a larger effort the
behavioral health administrator Jeff
Dill says there's ongoing mental health
seminars and work toward more counselors
and peer support teams Dill says between
juggling emergency calls and home life
it becomes very difficult and many
struggle with the Stress and Anxiety he
founded the firefighter Behavioral
Health Alliance to track things like
suicide since 2001 they've tracked 19
firefighter suicides in Nevada
but there could be more due to gaps in
reporting we lost three people last year
like in just our department alone that's
horrible
but I think that looking at it like
that's a place that we can grow through
tools like yoga and Beyond
an act to provide Mental Health
Resources to First Responders was
reintroduced in the Senate late last
month
the helping emergency responders
overcome or hero act paves the way for
annual reports on first responder
suicide rates risk factors and work
toward prevention as well as grants
toward peer counselors it was introduced
before in 2021 live near Bonanza and Las
Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News Now